For weeks they'd threatened to retaliate.
Then late Friday, Iranian Revolutionary Guard
commandos hovering over the Stena Impero,
made their move.
Raiding the British flagged oil tanker in
International waters.
And forcing it to sail to Iran.
Britain has demanded the release of the vessel
and condemned what it called a hostile act.
This is about the safety and security of British
and international shipping in one of the most
important seaways in the world.
That is why we are calling on Iran to reverse
this illegal act.
We are looking for ways to deescalate the
situation, but we`re also very clear that
we will do what it takes to ensure the safety
and security of British and international
shipping.
The Stena Impero is now docked in the Iranian
port of Bandar Abbas.
Its 23 crew said to be in good health.
But audio exchanges between a British warship
and the Iranian Special Forces moments before
the capture reveal the tension in the region.
"You must not impair, impede, obstruct or
hamper the passage of the Stena Impero."
"This is Sepah navy patrol boat.
No challenge is intended.
I want to inspect the ship for security reasons.
Over."
"Please confirm that you are not intending
to violate international law by unlawfully
attempting to boat the Mv Stena."
Iran's foreign minister on a visit to Venezuela
is said to view the seizure as tit for tat
following the impounding of an Iranian vessel
in Gibraltar earlier this month.
The Grace 1 was seized by British forces,
suspected of breaching sanctions on Syria.
For its
part the UK insists it's upholding international law.